und wir beginnen mit einem wirklich
schrecklichen fund in neustadt am
rübenberge niedersachsen hier wurden ein
mann und eine frau mittleren alters tot
in ihrem abgelegenen haus aufgefunden
die genauen umstände sind zwar noch
unklar aber die polizei geht von einem
doppelmord aus
flatternde absperrbänder und die
spurensicherung
verstörende bilder in der ländlichen
idylle des niedersächsischen neustadt am
rübenberge hier in diesem abgelegenen
haus wurden am montagnachmittag zwei
leichen aufgefunden
offenbar das paar welches hier lebte der
kriminaldauerdienst war hier vor ort um
umfassenden spuren zu sichern den tatort
aufzunehmen sowohl im äußeren bereich
als auch in dem wohnhaus nach einer
ersten auswertung in der ersten und
hatte aufnahme ist festzustellen gewesen
dass die beiden personen gewaltsam ums
leben gekommen sind das heißt eine
fremdeinwirkung spiel war ein besorgter
angehöriger hatte die polizei
benachrichtigt und die beiden anwohner
als vermisst gemeldet als die beamten an
dem einsam gelegenen haus ankamen fanden
sie die toten die spurensicherung war
mit mehreren teams im einsatz
die ermittlungen stehen aber noch am
anfang eine fahndung nach einem
möglichen täter wurde noch nicht
ausgerufen man müsse erst die umstände
abläufe und hintergründe klären so die
pressestelle der polizei hannover
und wir schalten jetzt direkt zu unserem
kollegen stefan sievering live vor ort
stefan du konntest dich dort auch schon
ein wenig um hören was weiß man denn
über dieses tote ehepaar
ich habe mich ein bisschen umgehört ich
habe auch mit dem bruder des toten
gesprochen der 59-jährige der hier
verstorben ist war 40 jahre bei der
deutschen bahn angestellt er hat er
jetzt jubiläum gefeiert seine frau hat
geputzt also hat ein bisschen dazu
verdient ein ganz normales ehepaar das
hier in diesem garten in dieser idylle
lebte mit gartenzwergen mit spielgeräten
für die enkel im garten
der ganz der ort steht hier steht unter
schock man kann sich nicht erklären was
hier passiert ist auch die verwandten
können sich das nicht erklären die
polizei steht ebenso vor ein rätsel
man sieht die polizei bereitet sich
gerade darauf vor noch mal hier nach
spuren zu suchen weil man irgendwelche
hinweise haben möchte was hier passiert
ist wer der mögliche täter ist ein
hinweis ist zum beispiel eine voller
briefkasten das könnte darauf hindeuten
dass die beiden eventuell schon länger
tot in ihrem haus gelegen haben oder
die polizei geht jetzt davon aus dass
sie möglicherweise schon seit dem 20 mai
tot sind zumindest wird jetzt gefragt
nach zeugen die seit dem zwanzigsten mal
hier an diesem einsamen feldweg
möglicherweise verdächtige beobachtungen
gemacht haben es werden jetzt auch
gerade sogar befragt und radfahrer die
hier land gehen ob sie irgendetwas
gesehen haben also möglicherweise liegt
der mord schon zehn tage zurück
und kannst du uns ein wenig die gegend
dort beschreiben man hat ebenso bild
gesehen von einer drohne aufgenommen da
steht dieses haus und drumherum ist
wirklich nur fällt oder
die ist nur fällt man hört auch gerade
einen bauern der hier vom von der vom
ernteeinsatz oder vom feld einsatz
kommen tiere sind rockenfeller
gerstenfeld weizenfelder es ist dieser
feldweg der hinführt ist zwar ein
kilometer lang ist eine sackgasse hinter
dem haus geht es nicht mehr weiter da
ist dann die güterbahnstrecke wo quasi
im fünf-minuten-takt güterzüge lang
fahren es ist also sehr einsam und
deswegen ist es umso unverständlicher
diesem wie sich ein killer hierher
verirrt haben könnte und was er gewollt
haben könnte wir haben ja zum beispiel
gehört das ehepaar wollte verreisen das
wollte über pfingsten wegfahren sie
hatten urlaub vielleicht wurden
einbrecher hierdurch sie überrascht man
weiß es nicht das ist alles spekulation
hinter dir sieht man auch den spielplatz
und auch ein swimmingpool hatte das
ehepaar denn kinder familie
das hatte familie es hatte kinder am vor
allen dingen es hat auch enkelkinder und
die spielgeräte sind für die enkelkinder
bestimmt die hier immer mal wieder zu
besuch kamen die wurden im nachbarort es
war heile welt ja bis gestern als die
beiden hier tot gefunden wurden stefan
sievering live vor ort bei diesem ganz
schrecklichen doppelmord besten dank dir